head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
what do you think about Elon Musk buying
Twitter and everything that's happened
so far well a sensible person would
probably say they're cautiously
optimistic
um the thing I've been following most
closely is his
so
um somebody uh sent me a telegram
channel that just kind of catalogs all
of his activity on Twitter
I don't so much look at what he tweets
because that's obviously you know
through the lens of you know public
management whatever
what's more telling and where I think
everybody kind of gives themselves away
is in those casual likes that happen at
two in the afternoon or two in the
morning you know and the way he
brutally
um
handled Kathy Griffin
what I look for when I um when I'm
trying to kind of work out what what's
really going on I try to think what's
making this guy smile you know what is
bringing this guy uh happiness
satisfaction Joy
um because that I find to be a a
reliable indicator of future Behavior so
I'm looking at some of the stuff that
musk likes and I'm getting a bit more
optimistic
and then you know when when he said um
she was in she wasn't uh she was
impersonated for she was banned for
impressing any comedian that's funnier
than anything that Kathy Griffin has
ever said that's true that's funnier
than her career and this tells me that
he takes great personal satisfaction in
seeing Justice served to those who have
been living high on the hog for far too
long
abusing and
um uh insulting uh
the rest of us while not allowing us to
respond in kind and that tells me that
he is
powerfully motivated to see Justice Done
publicly
so do you think that Kathy Griffin was a
good move or a bad move it's phenomenal
because it it it was
I mean Elon is the king of vaporware and
um and that's very frustrating but at
the same time he he has a sense of
theater and spectacle and
it was it was it it was it was
classically intelligent Elon because it
was just the right demonstration that he
meant what he was saying he put his
money where his mouth was he put one of
the most famous comedians in America in
the sinbin and then and then insulted
her amazing um and forced her to tweet
from her Dead Mother's Twitter account
which she then tried to play off as like
knowingly ghoulish but she just looked
weird yeah I mean she she's now I mean
she was she is a damaged figure anyway
um but she is a greatly diminished
figure as a result of this interaction
he didn't force her she decided to do it
herself which is disgusting in itself
she's well the mom thing was just kind
of like the the the
um clown World Capstone
the way in which he brought her to heal
by being funnier than she has ever been
which is supposed to be her job I mean
like who would go up against the
comedian on Twitter anyone because
they're not funny
uh because they're not allowed to be
anymore uh you know the basis of of
Comedy for centuries was laughing about
our differences so that we can realize
they're not that serious exactly that's
comedy and that's right because because
when you when you point out in an
affectionate way
um amusing amusing ways in which you
differ from somebody else has the effect
of bringing people closer together and
driving them apart um and a deliberate
misunderstanding of this is behind you
know the death of joy that I was talking
about but
he chose just the right person who had
already damaged herself with the Trump
head and therefore it was difficult to
defend
um to demonstrate that he really meant
what he said and then in a final Act of
sadism which I enjoyed
um he said I guess if she really wants
her account back she can have it meaning
beg he said he said for eight dollars
thirty dollars yeah which is which is
great too you can say what you want
about me that's gonna be eight dollars
yeah um but but he he basically said to
her
I have humiliated you in front of the
world you can come back but you've got
to beg me yeah
that's what I
in a sense we're speaking for all of us
in that moment and and we were all kind
of like this is what we've been waiting
for and we got a little glimmer of maybe
what we felt in 2016. and and
it but but it was more than that it was
it was putting his money where his mouth
was right uh not that he hadn't done it
already but I mean I think he borrowed
most of the money for the purchase but
um and put a lot of debt on the books
but who wouldn't uh it was it was it was
him showing us that he meant it he
actually did mean it and and telling and
and it was a it was a standby and stand
back or whatever it is uh it was a just
hold on I'm gonna deal with this you
made a very important point about comedy
healing society and I think one reason
why Society is so ravaged is because
comedy has been pretty much been made
illegal I remember your your Patrick
Ewing comment we don't have to get into
the specifics of it but I remember it it
just being hilarious but specifically if
you were given the chance one more time
to go back on Twitter would you take it
and how would your
um how would you post differently how
would you would you be different or
would you be the same everybody I know
has had a very different uh trajectory
after cancellation to me
um
I I'm sorry people are going to know who
I'm talking about and some of them are
friends and some of them used to be
friends but I've just seen people
um become just destroyed I've seen
people wreck themselves through this
like uh um
uh hysterical kind of manufactured grief
about a Twitter account it was never
that serious it was never that important
to me it was just one medium through
which I enjoyed amusing people but for
some people it was kind of all they had
um and many of those people have been
wrecked by this they're not the same
people they were in 2015.
um and and I I saw some of my friends
people I'd previously admired
doing this kind of you know pathetic
clamoring for some glimmer of former
relevance uh trying you know doing
anything at all costs to stay in the
headlines occasionally and I frankly I
felt that it was it was squalid and and
decrepit and beneath me and
um
um was absolutely not interested in
lowering myself to that uh so you know I
I think I've I think I've emerged from
it the most um psychologically uh intact
because everybody I know is was Driven
Crazy by it you know that um in uh in in
ancient Rome um when an emperor was
especially bad
um they would do something that was
later called damn nazio memorial so um
when the Emperor died they would chip
his name off buildings and smash his
busts
um uh with the goal of of erasing him
from history uh the idea was that you
know nobody would be able to tell in
future because you know in in Europe we
in western civilization we used to think
in terms of of civilization of legacy
yeah when when yeah when when uh when
the patriarchy was intact we
we thought more about that kind of thing
yeah um and and so the Romans were very
concerned about how um they would be
viewed in in future so when somebody was
especially cruel or Wicked or crazy
um they went to Great Lengths to erase
them from history
there's something oddly more more
sadistic and uh wretched is happening
now because people are alive to see
their own Erasure and that's new in
history there's no no there's no real
um close equivalent to that it used to
have banishment
well yeah sure but but you know you can
go and you can make a new life but to be
but to be forcibly
uh
installed on the sidelines watching as
your name and your like and your work
and your reputation is destroyed and
dismantled and um urinated on uh that's
something that not even the most
sadistic and insane Roman Emperor
suffered
and I can understand why a lot of people
find it traumatic
um perhaps I I had a bit more of a
healthy attitude to all that in the
first place so I didn't kind of feel a
existential loss of like it's a Twitter
account you know I still have my house
so I'll have my health
um you know uh I I I I it didn't it
didn't you know it didn't you know make
me wake up in a cold sweat thinking I've
lost everything
um as it did to some other people
because I think I maybe had a bit of a
better appreciation of what it
represented and what it didn't but but I
understand why they're why they're
traumatized you know
um it's been very it's been very
upsetting I personally would do nothing
different at all will you come back on
the platform I sorry that was your
question I don't know um I feel like I
mean I I kind of like
sort of Define that era and and me
coming back is going to be like a well
there's any all roads lead to some kind
of
um uh
some kind of um disappointing tribute
act to past glories you know and I don't
really believe in in in you know kind of
trying to resurrect uh past successes uh
I'm happy that they happened and and all
the rest of it but
I'm not somebody that can live that way
so I if I do it will probably be in a
very different format and a very
different style
um
I I I it's a battlefield that I
comprehensively conquered
um and I don't feel the need to revisit
it because I beat it uh I beat it so
much that you know
they had to Institute um you know the
regime that followed they had a hashtag
uh I can't say the word they had to make
rules because of you they did I mean it
set the trajectory for the for the
failure of the company you know
um and that's something I regard with uh
you know um Nostalgia and satisfaction
and I revisiting it would be to fall
prey to
um uh a a sort of debilitating
um temptation to live in the past I
found let me let me let me Rob you're
sorry Milo I want to ask you this
question because you talked about Legacy
in the Roman emperors I'm wondering if
you think the loss of that in modern
civilization that we that many people no
longer care about their legacy and their
history is a defining factor in why
things are the way they are falling
becoming darker yes it's a product of
women's suffrage
um the kinds of people who were
plausible candidates for office changed
when
um the voting base broadened
and I don't think it's controversial to
say that the Sexes are different and
have different
uh priorities and different uh
preoccupations and different ways of
approaching the question who do I want
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time